machine gun kelly [ __ ] murdered it
that guy yeah yeah he did great yeah he
was so it was so funny i've known that
guy for
for a couple of years right and he he
calls me up he goes dude
you're not going to believe this i'm
like what he goes dude i'm
[ __ ] playing you in the movie i was
like what
you know we're a lot of like like same
kind of flame and [ __ ] for sure
hyper and [ __ ] you know whatever and
so i was like no [ __ ]
way because we we we got updated uh once
in a while on who who was getting cast
and whatever but
i never saw his name come through i
didn't even know he was
so he goes dude i got the [ __ ] script
i'm coming over
i'm going to [ __ ] make you proud i
want to know exactly
what the [ __ ] every line i want to know
what went down
if it didn't go down like that how did
it go down i i want to [ __ ] nail this
and so we came over we spent a couple of
days going through the script and then
he went out and took like
four months of drum lessons
learning the spinnings and all the [ __ ]
that i do all my
what do you call those in twirling just
in i can't even speak intricacies
yeah yeah yeah yeah just my mannerisms
that's what yeah
when i play and dude i was like it was
so [ __ ] bizarre like i've never seen
somebody
that dedicated to nailing something he's
like i want to know this i want to know
that
don't take the lessons like and i'm i'm
going to [ __ ]
i'm going i'm going to murder this dude
this is so killer
and then on his tour like you know he's
a [ __ ] like a rapper but
every night on his tour his drummer
and the drummer and michigan kelly would
switch spots
yeah and then so that they could do
play the actual title track shout at the
devil yeah and play that song and
[ __ ] there's mgk
every night [ __ ] drumming away
playing shout out to the devil and
it was just incredible dude
that's so rad but and i think it's uh
rooks his drummer
is the is the guy who spent the time
with him for
those several months just showing him
hey this is how to do this this this
pretty wild man talented talented kid
yeah
yeah dude